We interrupt this broadcast
for an emergency alert.
The Department of Defense
is confirming reports
of an unknown object
entering Earth's atmosphere.
An alien artifact
landed on Earth.
We need to know why.
And they want me
to lead the mission.
-It should be six months.
-If all goes as planned.
I am coming back,
I promise you.
This is the most
important mission
in the history of humankind.
It's time.
Here we go.
We are on our way
to a planet full of aliens.
I found something.
How many of these
you think are out there?
Our first contact with
an alien civilization is a risk!
People will die!
We are all here
for the same reason:
to protect the lives
of the people back on Earth.
Wait, what's that?
Help me!
I am gonna get home.
Don't let go!
What's happened here
is gonna happen on Earth.
Oh God, no.
I have to save the crew.
Save Earth.
What if by doing this,
we launch
into an interstellar war?
We don't have a choice.